we're going to talk about error bars and
to talk about aerobars we're going to
use aerobars
these chocolate bars i don't think you
get them in the u.s we certainly have
them in the uk i've eaten a lot of this
chocolate in my time it's full of
bubbles
bubbly delicious goodness so we're going
to actually melt the bubbles well we're
going to melt the chocolate and we're
going to do it because we're going to
measure the speed of light with
chocolate
this is an experiment that's
you go anywhere in the internet you can
find lots and lots of people talking
about this experiment lots of people
have done this experiment in the past
it's not so much the experiment itself
what we're actually doing this for is to
put across the key importance of
experimental uncertainties and
experimental era bars and i can almost
feel the waves of
disgust as undergraduate students who
might be watching this or any students
might be watching this because
error bars in first year are something
that we spend so much time teaching
students about and let's be honest
they're not the most exciting aspect of
the science but they are absolutely key
because if you quote a result without
quoting an error bar you're not even
wrong if i can paraphrase paulie without
that error bar nobody knows what your
uncertainties are nobody knows how well
you did the experiment you can't compare
your result with any other experiments
so what we're going to do with this
chocolate is we're going to put it in
this microwave sitting in this fume
cupboard um i should note that the
reason we've got the fume covered and
we've got our smoke detector covered up
is that earlier today when i was
preparing this experiment
i attempted to do it in my office and i
didn't cover up the smoke detector and
the alarm went off in the building and
hundreds of people were evacuated um
that was
it was a big deal it was a big
embarrassing deal and the security
people are not happy with me it's a bit
like willy wonka's chocolate factory
isn't it look at that is there a gold no
okay right that's what it looks like but
we're actually going to
we're going to use this side some of you
will have seen this experiment but for
those of you who haven't what we're
going to do we're going to put it in
here
we're going to heat it up and it will
melt if the experiment works in specific
places and the places in which it melts
are directly related to the wavelength
of the microwaves so what's absolutely
key if anybody does want to do this is
you normally have a little rotating
thing the little um spindle that's the
word spindle that sits in here that
rotates the the plate round and rotates
the food round we don't want that we
want it to sit in one place and to be
bombarded so it doesn't
doesn't move around because that will
disturb the pattern
not that i can see anything
we might have to do this again we'll see
where we are and whether we've got any
oh oh no
yes it's definitely worked yeah there we
go
yeah okay one last try
it's melting it already there we go one
two three actually that was that was 20
seconds
now it's gonna take five minutes of
course
it's the yeah it's just a mess you can't
really see anything
oh it smells delicious
it's worked out okay about as as well as
the experiment works it's a very good
experiment to demonstrate this real
importance of uncertainties because
so often in science there's this idea
that you know science proves this and
science proves that and everything's so
exact it's not so they went in the
microwave and they were blasted for
various times between 10 seconds and up
to 30 seconds and as you can see
sometimes well decent imprints were
formed and then other times it sort of
formed a bit of a splodge in the
microwave oven you've got waves of
electromagnetic radiation and it's those
waves that are giving rise to the
heating of course
where you have peaks
in the electromagnetic radiation which
are called antinodes
you get a lot of
power injected into the chocolate and
hence it melts so what we're seeing this
pattern we're seeing is an imprint of
the standing wave pattern in the
microwave oven normally if food spins
round on that spindle we disabled that
spindle because what we wanted was the
opposite of what you normally want in
your food you don't want localized hot
spots we wanted localized hot spots
because those hotspots tell us about the
microwaves and the distribution and the
pattern of microwaves in the oven
so the distance between the peaks
within the oven
that is half a wavelength
because that is half that that's a
wavelength is where the whole cycle
repeats this is half a wavelength that's
all we need
that's that that's really we need that
and we need one other um equation which
i'll put in the microwave down here
which is this the speed of light
is equal to frequency of the microwaves
times
the wavelength frequency f let's write
it up here
is 2.45
gigahertz i know that because it's
written on the back of the microwave
oven so the important thing is that the
peaks here
between these tell us lambda over two
tell us the wavelength divided by two so
if we measure the distance between these
ah okay so that's about eight six about
seven okay so we've got three
three measurements we'd like to have
more
it's the first thing but what's the best
thing to do here let's take an average
so we've got eight centimeters six
centimeter and seven centimeter would
seem that the best thing to do is take
an aperture so let's say seven
centimeters that gives us a wavelength
of 14 centimeters
so c is equal to f times
14
centimeters
f we know is 2.45
gigahertz
because we read that off the back of the
microwave by 14 centimeters so we want
the speed of light which is c which is
in meters per second
so let's make sure we get we're careful
with our units so that's
2.45 a giga is 10 to the 9
hertz
by
in terms of meters that's 0.14
meters
what we have
is c
3.4 so
0.343 so that's 0.343
we could for the physicists among you i
know in terms of significant figures but
let's keep going
so c her result is 3.43
by 10 to the 8
meters per second that's the speed of
light that's the speed of light as
determined by chocolate that's not good
is it because we know what the speed of
light is and it's pretty damn close to
three by ten to the eight meters per
second
considering if you so it's actually
three and you've got 3.4 yeah on the
basis of chocolate i think that's pretty
good how do we know
good compared to what so can we really
quote to the 4.43 how many of those
figures are valid or significant or any
of those figures significant sometimes
we do experiments to try and um
check a previous value
and then often we do experiments because
we're reaching out into the unknown how
do we know could you do another 100 of
them another thousand of them we could
definitely do another thousand of them
but still then how do we know even after
those a thousand
how do we know well how do you know
anything exactly so what we have to
think about as this this value is quoted
we're not right we're not wrong we're
not even right we're not even wrong we
can do nothing with this value because
we don't know what the experimental
uncertainty is we don't know how well
we've done the experiment we don't know
how many of those figures are
significant we don't know
you know can we measure to the second
decimal place to the fifth decimal place
we don't know so we find that our value
ranges from 12 through 14 to 16. so our
value is 14 the best way to quote is
that we have lambda is equal to 14
plus or minus 2
centimeters
right
how does that translate into how we
quote our value for the speed of light
so we know we've got this value this
error in or in lambda so what we say is
we would typically you can either do a
big delta or a little delta typically we
call it a little delta i'll do a big
delta because my handwriting is
absolutely terrible so delta lambda is
equal to plus or minus two centimeters
or actually we'll just leave the plus or
minus out delta lambda is two
centimeters that's our error bar
so what we find is c
of what we know is c is equal to f times
lambda
we're going to assume because it's
written on the back of the microwave
that the frequency
we just got we've got no idea how you
know what error there might be on that
so we're just going to assume that it's
a given value that we don't know what
the area is so we're just going to treat
it as without an error it's it's a value
we've been handed down what we need to
do is work out the error in c depending
on the error in lambda but the problem
is well c is meters per second and
lambda is meters
and we can't compare we can't just go
this is um centimeters
then
we need a value in meters per second so
what do we do here well what we have to
do is look at something called the
percentage error or the relative error
so what we know is that delta c the
error in c in the speed of light over c
is equal to delta lambda
over lambda this is just basically
percentages that's all we're doing we're
expressing our error in c as a
percentage of c and that percent of the
percentage error in c would be the same
as the percentage error in lambda
because we're assuming this doesn't have
an error right so delta c
over c
is equal to 2 centimeters
over 14 centimeters
right
so our percentage error in c
is about
well as one over seven
that implies our error in c
delta c is one over seven times our
value of c which was three point four
three
by ten to the eight
so if we work that through work out what
1 7 of 3.43 is 0.49
by 10 to the 8th
now
the
standard approach and as long as we all
stick to this then everybody can compare
the results is that we quote to one
significant figure or if you're a bit
more careful and you can justify it like
they do in the national physical lab or
in nist may be two significant figures
we're going to do what um
is done in first-year labs across the
world
and we're going to quote that to one
significant figure
so that means our final result
for the speed of light
is
we've quoted this to one decimal place
so we need to get this to agree so we'll
get rid of the the
the three the second decimal place
without putting our error bar in place
the value of c the speed of light from
our experiment falls somewhere between
2.9 and 3.9 by 10 to the meters per
second now we can compare that to the
speed of light we really shouldn't
because that's not how you do
experimental science because it biases
you in one direction we should try and
do this as objectively as possible
without being skewed but we know in
terms of comparing that to the speed of
light
that we've done a pretty good job
because the actual speed of light falls
within the aero bar the problem is and
too often we have to correct this time
and time and time again in undergraduate
labs
the error bar the experimental error is
not the difference of the the value that
that 3.4 from the speed of light that's
not how you do it
it's not like it's a mistake and there
is no mistake there's a there's an
inbuilt uncertainty in our measurements
and there's an inbuilt uncertainty in
every single measurement we take doesn't
matter if it's to the nth decimal place
to the 10th the 15th to 20th decimal
place no matter how precise you get
you're never going to be
so precise that you're infinitesimally
precise
called the upside down and when he's
trapped there his mum is you know really
worried about him but she figures out
that he's not missing and actually she
can communicate with him when he's in
this parallel universe